spülmittel als mordwerkzeug in
hebenshausen in nordhessen wurden jetzt
zierfische scheinbar opfer eines fiesen
anschlags noch immer bedeckt eine dünne
schicht die zwei teiche im vorgarten von
michael rust der zierfisch züchter war
gerade im urlaub als seine mutter die
schreckliche entdeckung macht
ich war zuhause kriegte von einer
nachbarin hier anruft es sehe ganz
schlimm aus dem haus ich müsste sofort
kommen da habe ich mich auch gleich ins
auto gesetzt und bin hierher gefahren
und habe das denn vorgefunden mit so
einem riesenberg dass er aus als wenn
einer ein großes zelt hier über den
teich gestürzt hätte dicker fester
die rentnerin verständigt sofort ihren
sohn in der wiederum ruft die polizei
und die stellt schnell fest hier wurde
offenbar mit spülmittel hantiert 50
zierfische überleben das massaker nicht
die tiere sind qualvoll erstickt doch
was steckt dahinter
zerstörungswut oder doch nur ein dummer
streich wir haben sicherlich als kinder
auch streiche gemacht aber man sollte
doch damit streichen aufhören wo
entweder fremdes eigentum beschädigt
wird tiere gequält werden oder menschen
verletzt werden das geld dafür nicht hin
natürlich dass in einen brunnen mit
einem brunnen mache wo er wie wasser
sprudelt es schäumt und ich kann das aus
dass es hinterher wieder weg das ist
eine andere dimension als wenn ich das
irgendwo rein mache wo tiere leben
michael rost erstattet anzeige gegen
unbekannt hofft aber auf einsicht bei
den tätern
wissen sie wenn ich davon ausgehe dass
es sich tatsächlich um einen streich
handelt
dann sollten sie sich einfach bei mir
melden
und dass wir hier zusammen anpacken und
das ding wieder bereinigen
die fische kriegen wir davon nicht
wieder lebendig das weiß ich aber ich
glaube wenn die jungs oder mädels die
das gemacht haben vielleicht einfach aus
übermut sich immer zwei tage hin stellen
sich die finger abfrieren lassen die
steine immer sauber machen und so was
ich glaube das bringt mehr als wenn sie
mir tausend euro in die hand drücken und
sagen kauft ihr das zeug selber erst im
frühjahr hatte michael roß die teiche
angelegt jetzt muss er alles intensiv
reinigen und teilweise ersetzen
trotzdem will er die teiche wieder
instand setzen diesmal allerdings mit
videoüberwachung ich habe das jetzt
eigentlich gedacht was man das nicht
unbedingt braucht
aber es zeigt ja dass man doch auf so
etwas zurückgreifen muss auch wenn es
dann vielleicht das eine oder andere
problem für mich doch wieder bringt und
noch mal arbeit bringen aber das werde
ich mache einfach um mich aber auch
meine tiere zu schützen
der schaden liegt laut michael rost
übrigens bei vier bis fünftausend euro
plus die vielen arbeitsstunden die der
züchter in die tasche gesteckt hat mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bild schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren